Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 12th,
2016 what's going on?
How are you this wonderful,
wonderful football Monday fucking morning.
Um,
I'm actually recording this Sunday afternoon.
I think I'm going to be doing this and like two different chunks I'm going to do
before my show and after my show because,
uh,
I got to travel tomorrow on the podcast would be later than it usually is.
So,
um,
unfortunately,
uh,
because I've been on the road,
um,
I not seeing the UFC event yet.
So I know some people ask me if I was going to be talking about it.
I definitely will.
Very excited to watch it.
Uh,
but I will not see it until,
uh,
I'll be able to talk about it until Thursdays podcast.
So sorry to all the fight fans who like to listen to me and the my usual
ignorant completely not knowing what the fuck I'm talking about.
Way.
Uh,
talk about that fucking great sports.
So having said that,
it finally just dawned on me after living in Los Angeles since 2000 fucking
seven,
you know,
and also being there in the late nineties,
um,
that this is,
I'm finally,
it's finally dawning on me that we're actually finally going to have a,
a NFL team out there,
which is great because maybe I can finally see my patriots play without having
to fucking fly somewhere.
I could just go right down the goddamn streets would,
which would be tremendous for,
for a a man like myself sliding.
Yeah.
Into 50 years old,
48 years old,
man,
I want to fucking do this.
I don't know.
I can't jump on another southwest flight to watch Tom Brady pick apart yet
another fucking defense in some God forsaken stadium.
I want to go right down the street like an old man,
right.
When am I old man hat.
So I don't sunburn the top of my fucking baldhead be tremendous.
So,
um,
I also,
I know that they're building them a stadium and I,
I've been,
I've just been so busy,
I haven't even fucking thought about it.
And I'm like,
Bob,
tomorrow night,
Monday night football is going to be the rams first game in Los Angeles since
like 1995.
What the hell they playing this game?
It turns out that back at the,
uh,
the La Coliseum,
which is where they played when I was a kid back when I used to watch Pat Haden,
Vince Ferragamo,
that quarterback controversy,
Wendell fucking Tyler.
And then they also had a,
the young bloods,
Jim and Jack,
Young Blood Jack plane,
the Superbowl against the Pittsburgh Steelers played it on a fucking broken leg.
I mean,
I don't know if it was a compound fracture,
hairline fracture or whatever,
but his leg was fucking,
was broken and he's going gonna fucking play defense.
You assholes.
Sorry,
I've got a game on in the background.
Um,
I dunno why I love giants,
but I'm rooting for this kid on the cowboys.
You know,
Dak Prescott has been pretty good so far.
you know,
we started tell you,
what do you want me to do?
The fucking dumb analysis might tell you what I like about teach guy.
He's standing in the parking,
he's feeling the pressure,
he's got the clock in his head,
he's not rushing.
He's looking at second and third options.
Okay.
What we're seeing here is not what we saw last year when so and so was in there.
And he had,
he had the,
he was patting the ball telegraph and he's pitch it gives a fuck.
All I know is he's throwing the ball and guys with the same colored shirt,
uh,
catching it and they put putting points on the board.
It's 97 currently and I'm a join it very much the,
um,
you know,
eli is going to come back here.
He's going to stomp his foot.
He's going to make a fucking audible.
I love the Peyton Manning's fucking retired and I got to look at is dumb face
even more because he's going to be in every fucking commercial.
God bless the guy.
God bless him.
You know,
I should talk with my Charlie Brown have,
what would you rather have my Charlie brown he had or his a number two pencil.
Fucking neck and head.
That's it.
No,
it's a rough one,
you know,
but he's got the full head of hair,
so you've got to give them that,
right.
He's a hall of Famer.
He's got plenty of fucking money.
He owns part of Budweiser.
Yeah.
It's fucking asshole guy destroyed me.
Um,
you realize the ego on me that I actually just,
I just fucking mentally measured myself to a hall of fame fucking quarterback as
a what?
A Dick and shit joke.
Talent comic and an and a host of a fucking podcast where I sit,
I lie on sit.
I fucking laid down in God forsaken fucking hotels in the middle of nowhere.
You know what I mean?
I'm in Virginia right now.
Okay.
The state that professional sports for Gut Virginia is such a fucking enigma.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're in the south.
They don't have any professional teams and then their college teams haven't made
enough fucking noise.
You know what I mean?
Like if you're in South Carolina,
they don't have a professional team,
but they got,
they got Clemson,
they got the game cocks right up here.
You got Virginia,
you got Virginia Tech,
you know,
no fucking disrespect.
But you know,
last time Virginia was on the map for me was when Ralph Sampson Played Center
for your team.
You know,
and I'm not into fucking James Town and this bearded fuck who came over here,
you know,
what do you mean?
Pocahontas?
And he chopped down some trees and he made the first drive in movie theater and
he put his fucking hand up or a little fucking leather flap there.
Whatever the fuck have I,
I'm not into it.
The first settlements,
I don't give a shit.
I don't care about.
Almost said Tom and Jerry Thomas Jefferson's house.
It says here,
I don't,
George Washington is like,
I find that stuff just mind numbingly boring.
Okay.
I don't know what it is.
The civil war is interesting to me.
God knows they have some shit like that here,
but I don't know.
I Seeked it out World War II,
um,
did that,
that's like,
that's the good fellas of fucking wars as far as I'm concerned.
As far as,
you know,
the I footage of it,
there's been enough of the stories documented.
You know,
the got Ken Burns the war.
He did that whole great thing on World War II.
Um,
worldwide.
One fascinates me because nobody ever talks about it.
You know what I mean?
It's like a,
you know,
like the godfather part three,
you know what I mean?
Just like nobody really brings it up.
Well,
not really,
cause no one criticizes that,
but they trash got fun three,
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying,
but the revolutionary war,
the war that basically got us away from England and allowed us to become what we
are,
which is a tremendous nation and also tremendously fucked up.
Right.
But what makes us,
what we are meatball sub having fucking
country that we are,
it just bores me to tears.
There's something about powdered wigs.
There's something about buckle
on your hat.
You know what I mean?
There's just certain parts of history that either appeal to you or they don't.
And the fucking revolutionary war,
I could just give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
The revolutionary war to me is like when you watch highlights of the NBA in the
1960s and people are taking set shots and diaper shots and you know,
everything's considered a carry and nobody's dunking.
I mean what is exciting about a fucking war?
We got a bunch of guys in red coats standing up,
standing in line like,
like,
like they're doing a halftime show while you got a bunch of dirty,
filthy fucking Americans hide behind trees,
picking them off.
I just don't under,
it's just,
I mean it's just a bad game plan to begin with.
Um,
I like pirates.
I don't know when the,
when,
when the fuck did pirates and
I know recently there was a pirate movie cause Tom Hanks made the movie I love
about Tom Hanks is just like,
if there's any sort of heroic act,
it's like he has to play the part.
I don't give a fuck if you're in space.
All right.
If there's a d a disease,
he's done the disease.
He's been lost in space.
He's dealt with pirates.
I'm sorry,
my voice is fuck pirates.
He's fucking,
he's dealt with identity theft.
He's landed a plane in the Hudson River,
you know what I mean?
And he's great at all of it,
but it,
it starts to get to the point of like,
who the fuck does this,
Tom Hanks thinking is,
you know,
as much as he's doing all of this in the movies,
has Tom Hanks ever rescued,
rescued a cat out of a tree?
You know what I mean?
I,
I just don't understand where,
where he gets off accepting all these roles at some point.
I mean I always am.
I'd be like,
I have to go out and go do something heroic something,
you know what I mean?
I got to,
you know,
help an old lady cross the street.
Is that a weird thing to think?
Like if I was like one of those action heroes,
at some point I would have to learn how to fucking shoot a gun.
I'd have to get in a bar fight and you'd have to win.
You know,
it's some point or you just feel like it when you feel like an asshole and said,
how many times can you do that?
Bruce Willis?
Look over your shoulder when you raise up one eyebrow and you just catch the
camera crew looking at you.
And you know,
when they no one,
they could all beat the shit out of you and you sitting there in this fake third
of a plane,
right rudder.
But whenever the fuck you gotta Yell,
yeah,
Bill,
it's called acting.
You'd douchebag.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm just fucking around.
I love Tom Hanks.
You know what I mean?
He seems like a swell guy.
It's very wholesome.
You know what I mean?
It's funny.
He started off,
you know,
I don't think the religious right would have liked him,
when he was in the dress.
But I think gradually ease.
He's become very,
you know,
appealing to the people on Fox News.
He totally read himself.
You know,
like a lot of Republicans,
modern Republicans start,
you know,
at some point they're going to address right.
And then they apologize and they say that it's the booze,
you know what I mean?
And then,
then they just get super hardcore into Jesus where it was your Democrats,
you know,
they're,
they're fucking,
they're there.
They're in their bare feet and college walking around,
taking LSD and all that type of shit,
you know,
then they lie about it later.
Okay.
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
All I know is I just wish I could hit pause and never have this election
happened.
This has got to be there.
This is,
there's just,
there's no winning.
There's no fucking winning.
Um,
but for the first time ever,
I think I'm going to have to vote for one of the two fucking leading candidates.
I don't feel,
I know.
What are you going to him?
What are you going to do?
Yeah.
Worst case scenario,
you just deal with one of them for eight years.
You know,
long it's going to get Trump just to get somebody to fucking get the contract.
I piece of shit,
I'll probably give it to his own company.
Trump wall building.
Love.
His name's spelled out all over the fucking thing.
Um,
Bill,
why do you try to talk politics?
You know,
you don't pay attention.
Um,
all right,
let's plow ahead.
I was talking about the rams here and um,
does anybody know the,
you know,
it's funny as I'm on their Wikipedia page and somebody hacked it.
It's funny cause the owner's name right now,
his little bitch and the head coach is get a new one.
Um,
so I'm sure the rest of this stuff here is reliable.
team's history.
Now I actually
knew this.
I got all this stuff in front of me.
I knew some of this stuff.
I did know because I am a fucking nerd when it comes to sports that uh,
the rams initially started in Cleveland.
Why they would call the rams?
I have no fucking idea.
As far as I know,
there are no rams.
Okay.
I don't know if there's any fucking rams in the United States are there?
There's certainly not in Ohio.
There's definitely some buffalo off.
You know what the fuck?
I mean,
fucking Midwestern people do they,
do they ever not get seconds?
You know what I mean?
Look how they make their pizza there.
Rams.
Let's see here.
Rams in the USA by the guests.
I would say maybe Montana.
I didn't think they in Colorado
would want to be around all those dirty hippies out there growing weed.
Just fucking with you.
God bless him.
Ram Usa.
Do I literally have to write animal rams and USA animals that was going to have
a bunch of barefoot people at the fucking airport.
Okay.
Big Horn sheep.
Do you know you have to correct me every time.
You can't.
All right.
Big Horn sheep.
My,
my,
my mistake.
Oh,
hang on.
That's room service.
Alright,
I'm back.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
he's fucking
okay.
Goddamn sheep are all over the place.
They are in Colorado.
In your mind,
Wyoming and the Western project shall would you call it in North Dakota?
They are some fucking,
okay.
The appendix that hangs off of a Baja,
whatever the fuck you call it,
that hangs off,
um,
California.
That down there.
Not that in Cleveland.
Okay.
All right.
What the fuck was the point I was trying to make?
So anyway,
so they,
they were in Cleveland.
All right,
let's get the momentum going again.
Here it's five 57 I gotta be at the fucking place by six 30 here.
I haven't showered.
I haven't ironed my clothes.
Um,
okay.
Does anybody know?
Do they have the record for like moving the most?
It's gotta be for professional football team.
They were the Cleveland Rams from 1936 to 1945 and then they moved to Los
Angeles and they were there from 1946 to 1994 at some point they did play in
Anaheim.
I know that.
And then 95 to 2015 it was saint Louis Rams and now they're back.
So they've played one,
two,
three,
four different fork in places or three different places,
but they've moved to three,
four fucking times,
right?
CLEVELAND,
that was one,
two,
three.
Now they moved three times,
but they've been afforded some places.
No,
three different places,
but they weren't from Cleveland,
Los Angeles,
St Louis,
back to Los Angeles.
There you go.
All right.
How many fucking flights would that be?
That's how many times they went.
All right.
And um,
okay.
I told you I used to watch them way back the day,
you know,
Eric Dickerson,
he used to watch him.
The fucking,
uh,
who else did they have back there?
John Robinson is a coach then I remember that the guy from fucking USC,
but I'm psyched that they're playing in the a La Coliseum to see an NFL game.
There was huge.
I've obviously seen USC play there,
but I never saw an NFL game.
And that's huge to me because,
uh,
that's the site of the first two super bowls.
You know,
the first of which didn't even sell out wasn't even a Superbowl was a title
game.
The NFL AFL championship game,
whatever the fuck they called it.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I think I'm sort of going to be a rams fan.
I'm not going to root against him.
I'm not going to be a content.
Um,
I watch them.
Do you know who do they,
what do they play against?
I don't know what the divisions that when I was a kid it was so the rams,
the 40 niners the saints,
somebody else was in the NFC west.
Uh,
fuck.
Was it falcons?
And then the central was Chicago,
Detroit,
Greenbay,
Minnesota and Tampa.
I'm still looking at the poster when I was a kid.
I'm thinking of,
and then it was the fucking giants,
cowboys,
Redskins,
Eagles
and cardinals.
Right.
And afcs was the colts,
the Patriots,
the bills,
the jets and the dolphins.
Seattle was in the AFC.
West Adams has fucking nuts.
They move it all around now.
I don't know.
I don't even get it.
I don't know why they keep switching it up.
Maybe because it was to for travel.
I have no idea.
But,
um,
all I know is I got to get ready to go do my show.
So through the magic of the pause button,
you'll have to wait two seconds,
but I'm going to come back.
And,
uh,
having done my final show here in Richmond,
um,
but having a great time on this tour,
Todd rex has been fucking destroying.
Um,
and I want to thank everybody that came out to Charleston,
South Carolina.
We hit that cigar bar again.
Um,
you know,
I haven't worried worked out.
I've eaten like,
okay.
Or horrifically.
I,
I'm hoping,
you know,
we're five days in the road.
He's takes a rough one,
you know.
Um,
okay.
Charlotte was great.
Fucking Todd took me to this God damn one of those,
you know,
mom and pop chicken places,
right?
Which was fucking delicious,
but you know,
like 9 million calories.
I didn't eat for the rest of that God damn day after that place.
But,
um,
so we went there and then this friend of ours who was down there took us over to
the Charlotte Motor speedway and they got this thing called the NASCAR
experience where you can literally take this class and learn how to drive the
car and all that.
But you know,
we didn't have time to do that.
So they had a fucking NASCAR and they took us around the track doing about 165
miles an hour.
Took me first to then Todd and we sat in like the passenger seat,
like Luke Duke and went around and um,
okay,
I got to tell you like this is the amazing thing because they try to keep the
car so light.
You feel like you're in an absolute piece of shit.
I mean even like the,
the,
the gas pedal,
the throttle was like,
it was like the tiniest thing I've ever seen in my life.
It didn't even have the pedal on it any way that they can get out of the car,
they get out of the car.
So all it was,
I should've taken a picture of it.
It looked like a,
it was like the thickness of a fancy coat hanger and it kind of came up through
the floor and then just went up and like started to make the letter f but it
didn't have that short little one.
That's all it was.
I'm like,
your foot doesn't slip off that and the kids just laugh and go,
no,
it doesn't.
Even some 21 year old kid flying around the fucking track like 165 miles an
hour.
I gotta be honest with you,
I didn't do well through the first like lap and then I kind of settled into it.
Um,
I don't mind going fast if I'm the one driving,
but um,
yeah,
you know,
just sitting in a chair is someone else is going 165 miles an hour.
That close to the wall was pretty,
uh,
it was pretty God damn intense.
But,
um,
I want to thank everybody over it and at the NASCAR facilities for letting us do
that.
Um,
okay.
There I have to tell you instantly the heat,
the level of heat that was in that fucking car cause it was a really hot day.
I can't imagine with all those people watching all of those other cars driving
around the track how fucking hot it gets.
And um,
yeah.
And then also,
you know,
you kind of get thrown around the car a little bit.
Like I said,
it's not like you're riding in a Lincoln continental and,
um,
I don't know.
My biggest concern is smelling all those fumes and all that shit and just
driving around.
I probably get sick just driving in a circle,
like the level of concentration that it would take to just keep fucking doing
that for two and a half hours or however long it takes.
There'd be a,
I was just pulling the pit stop and just pay.
He had to do it.
I'm gay,
I'm gay.
I don't want to do with this anymore.
I did it,
went around the block coming to fucking times.
I got to do this.
I don't want to do this shit.
Um,
forget about actually hitting the wall.
That's why I just kept thinking about,
um,
for some reason I wasn't thinking about going in head first.
I was thinking about it.
If you've got spun around and you went,
you know,
rear of the car in first,
that's how bad that would fuck up your back.
Um,
but it was cool.
We got to ask the driver,
you know,
about some of his worst,
his course racks and all that type of shit.
And then,
uh,
we went down and did the show
and I'm one of these nights,
I did like a fucking two hours show.
I think that was in Charlotte.
I got to stop doing that.
I'm supposed to get my act out.
Oh,
about an hour and 20 minutes.
But I'm thinking this special is going to be somewhere between 1:20 AM one 30.
Um,
oh maybe.
Maybe they'll get it down.
I got to start time and it though.
But uh,
speaking in which that happens right now.
So I'm going to hit the pause button and uh,
I mean it does.
I don't know why I tell you guys this because it's just,
there's going to be no delay in your world,
but,
uh,
I'm off to go do my show here in Richmond,
Virginia.
Like I said,
thank you to everybody who shoot,
who showed up on this tour,
uh,
and having a great time and,
you've been helping me get ready for my special,
so thank you.
And uh,
I guess I'll let you know how my show went in about two seconds.
All right.
I'm back.
I am back show is amazing.
Amazing crowd.
Unbelievably beautiful theater.
Todd Rex fucking murdered.
And he told me,
guys,
he told me to tell you this story.
I can't believe.
I almost forgot this story.
It was such like a fucking Patrice moment.
It just,
so remind me of something Patrice would have done.
We would,
after we did Charlotte [inaudible],
we drove all the way up to a Norfolk,
Virginia,
which is like a five and a half hour drive.
And at my age,
I usually,
the cutoff is four hours.
You know,
back in the day,
I drive eight hours.
Then that became seven.
And then the cutoff was,
now it's just if,
if it's fucking for a pass in a ferrets,
17,
14 patriots,
sorry.
Um,
anyways,
um,
so we were fucking exhausted rice.
We walk into the hotel to check in and this cute girl,
right?
She was like 21,
22 adorable.
Just right out of college.
It's sitting there,
right.
And we get,
we check in,
right.
And she,
okay.
Before she,
you know,
she's handling this stuff,
she's getting all this shit ready.
Like,
uh,
she's going like,
okay,
just telling you about the hotel.
Um,
you know,
we have a restaurant here.
It's Italian food.
It's open from his time to this time and especially as a blah,
blah,
blah.
It's part of this Peneda on the second floor is the gym a second floor of the
gym but Blah Blah Blah.
And the top floor is this due to do the deal if you want it to this.
But when she goes to this big long speech and she's right in the middle of this
speech and Todd's behind me and I just hear him just go,
just give us the keys.
Okay,
I fucking died.
I put my head down on the desk.
She was so shocked that he said it.
But it was such a classic Patrice thing cause I was thinking,
I don't want to hear all of this shit.
I'm not gonna remember all this stuff.
I'm fucking exhausted.
I just want to go.
He said,
just the way he says it,
it always feels like this Archie bunker thing.
He goes,
just give us the keys.
And the poor girl,
she didn't know what to do.
She never,
you know,
she was younger.
So it took all,
I felt bad because it took us like a minute for,
to sort of regroup and then just realize that we were too silly older guys.
And then she and then said Todd
was rude but oh my God,
I haven't laughed like that in a long time.
And it really
reminded me of uh,
of Patrice,
which was crazy because tonight,
you know,
his mom came up to the show and his sister and uh,
I hadn't seen them was really just,
it was just the synergy.
So anyways,
let's plow ahead here with the podcast.
Um,
you know,
it would be fucking amazing in this first week here is if the Patriots win.
Cause I think I just saw the cults lost and I love Andrew Luck and I actually,
you know,
I like the Colson,
everything like that.
I just obviously you know,
the severity of this fucking stupid ass think it would be nice to see them lose
a couple of,
if we have the same record.
But then the other thing too is I don't want the colts to shit the bed cause I'm
hoping we're going to make the playoffs and um,
I want to play them again,
see what they're fucking excuse is going to be when we kicked their ass again.
And I'm saying we,
because I don't play for the team,
I should really be like,
hopefully we beat him.
Who the fuck knows?
But,
um,
okay.
I Dunno.
I,
this is,
I mark my words in,
in the history of sport.
Like this will go down as one of the most ridiculous fucking suspensions after a
while.
And I'll tell you why,
because I was literally just watching when I was trying to find this game.
Um,
they had a thing on the Celtics and a that time Dennis Rodman set,
if Larry Bird was a black guy,
you know,
he's a very,
very good basketball player,
but if he's a black guy,
he'd just be another good player.
And,
um,
and then they asked what does his face Isaiah and I was Isaiah was like,
yeah,
I'd have to agree and how that whole thing blew up and blah,
blah,
blah.
So now it's like 30 years later and now they're actually saying,
well,
you know,
they're actually kind of defending Isaiah,
not saying what he said was right,
but they're looking at it like Isaiah.
Unfortunately in that time he said the wrong thing about the wrong white guy.
And now,
now it's much more like measured how they're looking at it.
I think that'll happen if the fucking time.
I hope so.
I just said for Tom,
like I was like part of his fan club.
I hope that happens for Tom.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
just an absolutely incredible run.
Um,
I'm telling you,
people sleep on the south.
They really do.
How fucking great it is down here.
Um,
but like I said,
I've never been tailgated the way I was tailgated from fucking South Carolina up
to Charlotte and Charlotte over to Norfolk,
Norfolk over the fucking
Richmond.
They get down to these two lane highways and I'm telling you,
they are the,
it's like a NASCAR race.
They're right on your ass there.
Um,
so anyways,
I got to do a couple,
unfortunately I have to read out loud.
I know you guys get a nice fucking enjoyment out of this.
Let me just knock these things out because I'm going to go down the street and
have a Sas Barilla with Todd Brexit.
Jesus fucking Christ he murdered on this.
People went out to my show was a lane about that guy.
How funny is he?
He's so fucking silly to sell.
He's one of my favorite things ever.
Um,
so anyways,
here we go.
Oh Jesus.
All Right,
dial is shave club.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club keeps getting better.
They started four years ago by delivering their amazing affordable razors and
they've grown to over 3 million members who no longer overpay for a quality
morning shave.
And now new members can get their first month for free.
Dollar Shave Club is about,
is about so much more than just razors.
They have a mission.
They want you to look,
smell and feel your best.
And they've been investing millions in R and d developing whatever the fuck that
means.
Their original grooming formulas for your face,
hair and body.
This stuff is amazing.
How,
how exactly do you work on that?
You know,
you just find people that a Walmart that will loan their face to your fucking
products and you make sure it doesn't mess up their face.
Is that what it is?
20 to 14 patriots cause up.
It's good.
By the way.
Cardinal fence that pass interference call in the end zone.
That's set up the field goal for 20 to 14 uh,
your rate,
if you said that was bullshit,
that dude literally started falling down.
He reached out and grabbed the other person like it was falling off a boat.
All right.
Anyways,
okay.
This stuff is amazing.
Evidently pre and post shave formula,
skin protection formulas or do they shave the face of a rabbit?
They're always using rabbits.
You know,
rabbits have such a brutal life that I think that's why God let them fuck as
much as they do.
Because if they're not getting eaten by a snake,
we're rubbing shampoo into their eyes and stuff,
you know,
cut their feet off so they can,
we can be lucky.
Um,
the staff is amazing.
Preimpose shaped formulas,
skin protection,
farmers,
killer hairstyling products,
and literally the most amazing soap and body wash she'll ever use.
Hairstyling products.
I can't remember the last time I had to use those
as the thing about Moose in the late nineties.
Uh,
the store experience is awful.
All this stuff looks the same.
There's too many options and no one's there to help you find the products that
are right for you.
It's not true if you're going into the ladies' part,
they always have somebody always wearing a lab coat.
Like they went to fucking medical school.
Thank you.
Put clown makeup on fucking
soccer moms.
Right?
What's with this mark?
Do you have any idea why you picked the shampoo or body wash should do seriously
just get all your grooming stuff shipped from dollar shave club.
You don't have to deal with that shit anymore.
Give it a try.
Once you get in there,
you'll see the products work.
Amazingly.
The service is world class and there's no commitment,
no hidden fees.
What makes it world class that you order it and they ship it to you.
You can't.
So whenever you want,
get your first month free@dollarshaveclub.com slash bird just pay for shipping
after that.
It's only a few bucks.
Dollar Shave club.com/birth
all right,
two more.
Everybody hanging there.
MVMT watches Michael Vincent,
Michael Thompson,
uh,
when you were in your early twenties and thirties,
money can be [inaudible]
tight
if you're not careful,
dressing well can quickly drain your bank account.
Like spending 400 to $500 on a department store.
Watch,
uh,
there's some brands out there changing,
charging insane prices for watches that aren't even worth it.
Well,
if you want to look great when you go out,
but still have enough money to buy him or her a drink,
checkout movement,
watches.com um,
I've seen them before of a deadly in these watches.
A sharp,
actually,
yes,
they've sent them to me.
They're very sharp until you touch them.
Then you're like,
oh,
that's not a thousand dollar watch.
Originally founded by two broke college kids moving watches,
cut the middleman out and that big brand retail markups in order to give you a
stylish watch for an affordable price move and watch his star for just 95 bucks.
I'll watch with department store quality for a fraction of the price.
They're sleek,
minimalistic,
and a modern twist on a classic style movement has grown organically purely by
supporters like you were will.
So join there more than 1 million social media followers and get movement
watches today.
Go to MVMT watches.com/burr and they'll give you 15% off your entire purchase.
It's MVMT watches.com/bar
finally,
lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com everybody a fucking asshole.
Beat the blitz.
Nice play Carson.
Calmer year,
wily veteran,
um,
trips to the post office have probably becomes second nature to you.
You put on your slippers,
right?
Take off your jam jams and you walked down the street with your hog hanging out
like everybody does when they go to the post office.
They seem easy because you've been doing it mailing and shipping that way for so
long,
but think about the hassle if you really think about it.
All right.
Oh,
you knew you were getting a flag on that one.
Butler,
that's fucking Fitzgerald and he's a fucking premier player.
Let's take a look at this again,
shall we?
Yeah,
she interfering,
joined the boot,
cut Fitch.
It's going to be a first down,
but it was still running his mouth.
Whatever do when it counted,
you pick the ball off and you send everybody in Seattle crying.
All right,
that's a bit of a chuck there.
Yeah,
dude,
come on.
You bumped into him.
It's still bullshit.
Back in the day,
it wouldn't be a flag anyways.
Okay.
Trips to the post office is probably come second.
I,
where the fuck am I?
Okay.
You know what I mean?
You used to go into the fucking post office,
right?
But if you really sit down and think about it,
I think what you have to do,
you have to drop what you're doing.
You've got to drive there.
You have to find parking.
You got to wait.
You've got to sit behind that dose with 58 boxes.
Are you going to fucking tackle that guy?
Jesus Christ down to the 10 anyways,
stamps dot coms.
It's way easier,
more convenient way to get posters right from your desk.
They make it easy to get the exact postage for any letter,
any package.
I bounced to the outside.
Oh,
come on.
It was like five miss tackles there.
That's going to be on like,
oh my God,
that was terrible.
That was terrible.
That right.
That could have cost him the game.
That's going to be one of those things when they do the fucking Sunday night
countdown,
whatever the hell they do there,
they're going to have the numbers.
Let's count the guys that missed a one,
a two,
a three,
four,
five,
maybe seven guys had a shot at them.
Where are we?
We're at the post office.
All right,
so they make it easier to any postage,
any letter,
any,
any fucking thing you want to do.
No expensive postage meter to lease or no more trips to the post office.
You simply have to try it.
I use stamps.com anytime I send out my posters,
which I'll be doing when I work in DC,
I'm going to make a poster there,
few peoples,
um,
if I can figure out how to use it.
So can you sign up for stamps.com and use my last name bur for this special
offer,
four week trial plus our Henry $10 bonus offer.
Uh,
including the postage and a digital scale.
I,
they say it's a special offer at your offer.
You've had this offer since I've been advertising this.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
bar.
Ah,
right.
Okay.
Let's get back to the,
uh,
let's get back to the podcast too.
Alright,
what's 21 and 12?
Everybody?
Why that's 33 minutes?
I think it's time.
Nice stiff arm too.
Shit.
I think it's time to do some.
Uh,
let's do some questions here for the week.
All right,
mother Theresa.
No,
GS is Mother Teresa.
She's up there rubbing Jesus's head at this point.
Um,
hey there,
Billy angel tits.
Uh,
you creative cons.
Um,
way back when you talked about Mother Teresa,
I don't even remember this and how overrated she was.
You didn't like her quotes that the US was morally bankrupt in that pub then
that the poverty of spirit in the U s was the worst poverty she's seen.
Including the hunger poverty in India.
Yeah.
I don't like people.
I don't like people who don't live here talking shit about my country.
If you want to shit on the u s and you live here,
I don't have a fucking problem with that.
I do have a problem with the fact that the car knows almost just scored there.
Um,
yeah,
we had been shut the fuck up.
You know what I mean?
Why would you talk shit about another country?
I mean I do it,
but that's cause I want to sell tickets.
There.
You know,
you talk a little bit of trash.
Them selling the fight.
That's all.
Wow.
What a battle between Butler and Fitzgerald,
Hun.
He's hanging in there.
Oh,
we should have caught that.
All right.
Sorry.
I'm going to stop watching the game.
No,
I'm not,
but I'm going to stop talking about it.
How about that?
All right.
All right,
so I didn't like her talking shit about the country.
Well now she's got to be a sink.
There are plenty of documentaries of things she did that had negative effects.
Any thoughts on the Old Lady?
Come back to Seattle?
Well,
here's the deal.
When somebody gets made a saint,
it's a,
it does not cause they did nice things.
First and foremost,
you had to make the Catholic church money,
right?
Is that who she works for?
And what she did by going around with all these poor people was,
she was like out in the field.
You know what I mean?
She's like that cop that never wanted to have a desk job wanting to be out on
the beat,
be there with the people.
But the whole time she's selling that religion and it made them millions and
millions of dollars,
it took millions and millions and millions of dollars out of these poor people's
heads,
you know,
to basically invest in a fucking theory that has no,
no proof whatsoever.
Basically invest all this money in.
Um,
ah,
you son of a bitch.
Oh,
that's Fitzgerald.
He's 11.
I thought he was 15 and I'm a fucking dope.
Nice catch.
God Damn it.
He's a great player.
Ah,
Shit.
What the fuck is this going out?
I would really,
I liked the cardinals fan,
but I really love the Patriots and when just cause the colts loft.
Look at the guys almost like an upside down.
Bounces it on his finger.
Does he have control?
Does he make a football move?
Yes.
He fucking caught it.
If they take this thing away,
I swear to God,
I don't even know.
What do,
what does the guy you have to do?
Did he secure it up against it?
Um,
yeah,
so I think she's a saint.
You know,
she,
you know,
she wants,
look,
even if she fucked over the poor,
she's still,
they'd be down there in some of basically who's kidding who,
some of the stinky as smelly as parts of fucking humanity because you know when
you have that level of poverty,
you know,
and they don't have running water and stuff,
people that just shitting everywhere.
You don't that alone,
the fact that you,
if you have access to first-world plumbing,
if you go into the third world to try to help those people out.
Yeah,
I think you are a saint.
I would think so.
Granted she sold them,
you know,
the whole fucking bill of good stereo with a mass murdering,
child raping entity.
But other than that,
I mean,
so you know,
when those people say you're a saint,
does that really mean something?
I'm going to be honest with you.
I have no fucking idea what she did.
I know she was like Alicia keys and she didn't wear makeup.
I do know that.
I don't think she could play the piano.
Um,
yeah,
I have no idea.
Well now she's going to be a saint.
Look,
she's dead.
You know,
I,
I made fun of when she was alive.
Now she's dead.
I think I can leave it alone.
All right.
Lobster,
anesthesia,
all Billy red lobster,
red.
You don't have never eaten at a red lobster.
I just never had the courage to fucking eat like fast food,
seafood.
It just,
it always seems like if anything's going to give you food poisoning,
it's going to be,
you know,
the bottom feeders of the ocean right there.
We're already eating the fecal matter there,
right?
So,
uh,
the only time I've ever been to a red lobster,
I actually performed there.
I remember a long time ago I did a standup show in a red lobster,
but this fucking hilarious comedian Julie Bar and a couple other people.
And it was just one of those shows early in my career where you're going in
there and everybody on the show before we go up,
we all know we're going to take a fat one.
It's going to be difficult.
And you just laugh and you just stand there going,
this is fucking impossible.
This families here,
are we allowed to curse what's going to happen?
People got bibs on the train and they try to navigate this fucking little red
dinosaur in their plate.
How the hell are you going to listen to me?
I suck when they're paying attention,
you know?
So anyways,
let's get back to red lobster here.
Those acts,
there actually is a method that is supposed to,
and he said,
I'm no lobster neurobiologists to numb lobsters before you boil them.
You stick the lobster in the freezer for a few minutes.
Yeah,
before slicing it through the brain.
The freezer is supposed to be the most humane way because at least
when people start to freeze to death,
they eventually feel a warmth go over them and they start to become unconscious.
Supposedly this helps the flavor because the anesthesia does creased,
dis decreases the stress hormones release compared to the dude being boiled.
Well conscious or having its brain shopped and half like the obituary saw.
Hope this helps and have a blessed day.
Fuck Fucko um,
okay.
If you stick a lobster in a freezer for a few minutes,
it's just going to freeze.
It's just going to be really cold and be miserable and then you're gonna stick
it in the fucking hot water.
I just,
I,
you know something.
I'm never eaten lobster again.
Okay.
They do enough bad shit.
The chicken and cows and stuff,
I don't need to add this.
It's just so fucked up.
I was watching this thing on this French restaurant and this guy takes these
live lobsters and puts him over an open flame.
It's just like,
yeah,
I always go back to that time.
I watched that chimpanzee catch that smaller monkey and he stood on the thing
and he just started just digging into his back,
pulling it's back,
meet out is this thing was screaming.
It's just like when for fucking animals,
man,
there's no fucking reason to do that,
man.
I still think what I'm saying is better.
You just take a little lobster bat.
You Bash it over their head immediately unconscious.
Like if somebody hit you in the head is hard as it could with the bat,
you're not going to feel any pain.
You're not even gonna fucking remember it.
He can't do that to those things.
I don't know.
It just seems wrong.
All right,
so it's 2120 we just took a fucking sack.
Nice play.
God dammit.
Bull Rush.
Jones right up the fucking middle.
Gave us the old right there,
Fred.
But you know what?
Look at fucking Jimmy graph below here.
Garappolo he's doing great.
We're hanging in there.
Cardinals are no slouches right there.
They always go to the Superbowl last year
while we even held on that play.
Yeah,
gave a little spin move.
Alright,
grumpy below goat.
Billy goat.
Terrorizes town.
All right.
Evidently I'm supposed to watch this.
All right,
I'll watch it.
Here we go with my hotel.
Internet.
Yeah.
Oh,
this is great.
I love coach.
So it was just two people on a scooter.
It's fucking thing.
Just knocks him over by watching late.
You got to feel the backside pressure,
backside pressure.
Get rid of the ball.
Are you looking for the Tom Brady fucking treatment?
Yeah,
that's it.
No flag there.
C'Mon UFC.
You can't kick when they're down.
I look at this guy coming in.
There you go.
Front kicked.
Fun Kid.
Always going like,
what's his face there?
Come on man.
What do I root for you?
This is,
this is,
you know what?
Come on.
I want the guy in the striped shirt.
There you go.
Kick that motherfucker.
You hit your lady.
This thing's a pimp.
Should have kicked it right and it's fucking other
dude.
I would grab that thing by his fucking head.
Is that a cop?
That's hilarious.
This is definitely another country that was a cop here,
that fucking shooting.
He loves that.
Doing the stripe shirt.
Sky's going to slip and fall and crack his head.
Dude.
He runs like a girl.
Come on man.
How was that was interesting.
I like to,
I like,
yeah,
I love Goldsmith.
The thing is that you can't,
you can't show any fear,
man.
I like how that guy was trying.
He was trying to give him the,
the,
the front kicks,
like the Anderson Silva.
Right.
Um,
all right.
I don't know why.
I Dunno.
Why?
Why the fuck would I watch that?
You guys can't see it,
right?
Well,
you know what?
Grumpy bill.
Billy goat.
Terrorizes town.
That's what you want to look at.
If you want to see the commentary there and where the fuck was I?
All right.
I love goats,
man.
I've ever tell you that shit.
Like that's the best of pet I should have had.
They just smelled really bad though.
But like,
you know,
they have like,
I was like wrestling with my dog and shit,
but it makes the dog aggressive.
But goats are already like that and they live outside.
So then I couldn't be anywhere near your company.
I should get,
you know,
that's the next thing I'm like,
I'm going to get a goat,
right?
I just have it in a pen.
Get it a friend.
Right.
They can fucking hang out.
And then every morning I'll come out there and I'd be like,
what's up?
You know,
reach over the fence,
grab it,
bites beer,
get a little fucking Yankee,
you know,
get the thing going.
Wrestle around with it for a little bit.
All right.
Dad Won't quit smoking.
Oh,
Jesus.
Your Dad will not quit smoking.
What the Hell's wrong with him?
He's going to,
it's going to kill himself.
All right.
Hey,
Billy.
Red Nuts.
My Dad's been smoking since he was 14 years old and it's 62 years old.
He recently had his second heart attack.
Jesus Christ.
The doctor has told them flat out.
Okay,
if you want to live,
you have to talk.
You have to stop smoking.
MMM.
Yeah,
I would think so.
Even after hearing this,
he lit up a cigar five minutes after getting out of the hospital.
I got into a huge argument with him about it and I told him,
if you didn't give a shit about his health,
then I shouldn't care either.
We didn't talk for months.
Wow.
Dude,
this is fucking heavier.
Uh,
we've tried to,
we've tried reasoning with him.
We've tried to yelling at him.
We've tried guilting him with a don,
you want to walk me down the aisle routine.
None of it works to clarify.
He smoked cigars every single day,
all throughout the day.
So it's more than an occasional puff.
Uh,
his diminishing health is visible in his everyday interactions with us.
It's harder for him to breathe.
He can't,
is he inhaling?
He can't walk as fast as or as far as he used to.
He can barely play with his grandkids and his face his age to immensely since
the last heart attack,
every time I get a call from a family member,
I get anxious that it's going to be the call telling you my dad has had his last
heart attack.
It's,
I'm constantly on pins and needles and it's really starting to affect me.
Yeah,
I would think so.
Uh,
is someone who has struggled with certain vices yourself,
what finally made you feel like you want it to limit your intake?
Uh,
is there a way I could get through to my father and get them to quit for good or
should I just accept the fact that we all go someday and let him enjoy himself
for the limited amount of time he has left?
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
All right.
Wow.
Um,
okay.
All right.
What makes me want to limit my intake is cause I don't want to end up being like
that.
MMM.
But I also,
I don't know,
I don't like having shit have control over me,
you know what I mean?
And,
uh,
I also found that like when you just smoking
a cigar,
you know,
if you smoke too much,
like they,
they're not special anymore.
Like,
it's great when,
you know,
I like now just planning a cigar night,
like a couple of weeks away,
like a,
the absolutely fucking hilarious.
Bert Kreischer is,
um,
one of the great guys you could have a hang out with,
forget about smoke a cigar with,
he's trying to organize a cigar night.
And um,
I already have it circled on my calendar.
I'm excited.
I'm thinking about what cigar I'm going to have.
But like when I just,
you know,
have a whole box of them and every night I'm just going out there smoking.
It's just,
he starts smelling like a cigar.
It's bad.
It's like,
you know,
if I'm drinking every night,
I dunno.
It's just one of those things where I don't like the way I feel.
I don't like the way I feel when I wake up in the morning.
And I know it's bad.
I know it's aging me.
I just know,
I know it's bad for me.
But with your dad that he's been doing this for so fucking long.
MMM,
I would definitely,
I would be livid at my dad if he was doing that and I would be unbelievably
frustrated and I would continue obviously to try to get them to stop because you
love your dad,
you know?
However,
there does come a point where it's just like,
if
the person has resigned themselves to,
this is what they want to do.
I mean,
if he just had his fucking second heart attack and the doctors going,
listen,
you're going to die if you don't stop smoking any walks out and literally just
lights up a cigar.
Um,
obviously he's a complete addict and,
but
I dunno,
he's not fighting it on any level.
So,
um,
I dunno,
depending on how exhausted you are.
I know myself,
after awhile I would just say,
you know what,
fuck it.
Um,
and it would suck because when my dad,
if my dad died like that,
I would,
there would be a definite level of resentment and anger that I would have had
him.
But I,
I just think maybe the piece you can find is that he's addicted.
He's an addict and this isn't your father making this decision.
It's the chemicals and all of that shift that makes you make sure you do this.
That's really unfortunate,
man.
There's really nothing funny in there.
Jesus.
I was going to smoke a cigar night too.
Um,
well I guess that's fucking,
that's out the God damn window.
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
start to shake that off.
All right.
Uh,
advice strip club with wife.
Oh,
Jesus.
A builder.
Uh,
that's a good one.
I've heard that one before,
but it's always nice to bring that went back.
Me and my wife in six of our friends are planning a trip to Vegas early next
year.
Bars,
strip clubs,
the whole Shebang.
I'm 27 and my wife is 26.
We've been married for four years.
I was wondering if you are near or past girlfriends have gone to strip clubs
together and if so,
what's the etiquette?
Neither me and my wife had been to a strip club before.
Obviously I wouldn't mind taking in the sights,
but also don't want to be a piece of shit.
Oh God,
this has fucking train wreck written all over.
Okay.
I know this isn't exactly something on my wife's bucket list,
but I don't think she'll hate it either.
She's told me in the past she appreciates the female body.
Not necessarily grinding on mine though.
MMM.
I think she probably enjoyed it more.
If I wasn't there.
Lol.
Would love to know what you and near would have to say on the subject.
Thanks.
Well,
Nia is not here.
This is what I would say.
Okay.
Um,
okay.
You need to stay as sober as humanly fucking possible and you need to not
indulge it all.
Your indulgent should be,
is your wife enjoying the experience?
That's what should do.
All right.
And,
uh,
I would not get a fucking lap dance in front of my wife.
I would not do that.
Not that my white Neil wouldn't give a shit,
but my wife is like ridiculously fucking cool.
My wife is honestly one of the coolest females.
She,
she transcends her sex.
The only reason why I say she's a cool female is because so many of them are
fucking nightmares and they won't let you do anything.
They won't let you have any fun or whatever.
Like she just,
you know,
gee guys here on the podcast,
she's,
that's not an act.
She's that fucking cool and funny,
but most people are not in that situation.
So it's the,
there's a few red flags in there.
You're going with other couples,
like let the other couples get into the fights because somebody is going to go
to fucking far,
somebody's going to get too drunk.
Somebody gonna fuck up and somebody is going to have that fucking thing brought
up for the next 10 years in their fucking marriage because God knows that's what
the fuck they do.
So all your mission that night is,
is to not be that guy.
Strip clubs are not going anywhere.
Okay.
You can always go to one another night when she's not fucking there.
Or if she actually ends up having a good time the second time and just literally
tell,
just say,
listen,
I wasn't going to get drunk and I was going to do anything to embarrass you,
then she'll fucking respect you.
So I would just say go really easy on the booze there and uh,
you know,
get your wife a fucking lap dance.
That's what you do.
And then just,
you know,
yeah.
And just say,
you're good,
you're good.
You know,
and when you're fucking friends are all trying to pressure you into doing some,
just tell him to go,
you know,
Jay,
yeah,
I'm cool.
Don't worry.
I'm having a good time.
Okay.
And let them do all the dumb shit.
Let them wake up the next day.
When you guys go to breakfast and be the ones that have to say,
hey,
say hey,
look crazy and or be the ones that are clearly just had a huge fight and are not
talking during breakfast.
You don't need that shit.
All right?
It's a very,
um,
all of that type of shit.
There's like when you're sitting there going,
what are the rules?
The rules are the rules,
rules that you and your wife come up with.
And um,
the fact that your wife has never been to one is just all of the fucking makings
of a shit show.
So like I said,
I'm not going to read it.
I'm gonna say this again because you were a young guy.
Do not be the drunk guy.
And I'm telling you,
just make sure she has a good time.
Ask her if she's all right,
ask her if this is cool.
If she wants to get out of there,
just totally be attentive to her and there's no way it can be a fucking problem.
And then you can get on with you God damn life and then fucking whatever.
Some other time you go to a titty bar,
maybe you bring her along,
you know,
she might fucking end up wanting to see you get a fucking lap dance and you're
like,
you serious?
Yeah.
And then she'll be like,
all right,
which one do you want?
You know,
and then that's another thing that could be
be a fight.
You know what I mean?
You fucking pick some,
you know,
I don't,
that's just one of those,
it's just,
it's just one of those things.
I remember one time,
um,
there's this famous,
strip club in Los Angeles called jumbo was clown room.
Okay.
And it is just as creepy and disgusting as it sound.
I don't think it's not that anymore.
It's,
it's way better now.
But back in the day,
it was literally like,
you know,
if I was a serial killer,
like that would be my Starbucks,
you know what I mean?
Sit there with my laptop in a chat room with other serial killers.
I mean,
it was a fucking disgusting place.
So,
yeah,
I had been there,
uh,
maybe three times over the course of 20 years going out to La and it was always
just a shady shifty fucking place.
So one time,
um,
I was out with Nia and she's brought up that she wanted to go to this fucking
place and I was just like,
are you serious?
You want to go to that place?
I don't want to go to that playground other places.
It's not a cool place where I'd have since she goes,
come on,
let's just go.
So I fuck it.
Let's go.
It was her fucking idea.
So we ended up going there.
By the way,
it's 23,
21 with three 38 to go.
I already know.
You guys know who won this fucking game
lag on the fucking cardinals.
I love it.
Take it back.
By the way,
I forget the cardinals coach man,
but I saw a great,
uh,
they did a whole on the guy.
Seems
like the fucking coolest dude ever.
Um,
but anyways,
um,
so we ended up going there and I sat over in the corner.
I didn't get a lap dance or anything like that,
but I think I've told this story before.
I literally saw a stripper quit on stage that night.
It was fucking amazing.
Um,
we walked in and there was like one guy sitting up near the stage and there was
like three other people up at the bar with their backs to the stage.
So this woman comes out
looking a little rough,
you know,
and uh,
she starts doing the things,
she dances to one song,
the song ends,
nobody claps.
Okay.
The guy who was sitting up near the stage was not there anymore.
So now it,
it kind of becomes like a philosophical,
philosophical question.
Like basically if I'm in a strip club dancing,
but nobody's watching me,
am I technically still in show business?
Right.
So basically what happened was,
you know,
no one was fucking paying attention.
So she ends the first song,
you know,
cause I'm won it dead or alive.
She slowly slides down the pole and then the next song starts and she's just
laying there and she's not dancing,
she's not doing anything.
And I'm going like,
oh my God,
this was like watching a boxer,
like not answer the belt.
Right.
And just quitting on the stool.
And She just rolled over and somehow she had her cell phone and she just started
checking like her fucking emails.
And at that point,
like this,
one of the bar back ladies walked by,
saw it and laughed and said,
that's awesome.
And she just laid there for the rest of the song and didn't dance and gathered
us shit.
Didn't take up any more of a close.
And then like she quit being a stripper.
She just quit
dancing for the night.
And uh,
I thought it was fucking awesome because fuck it Larry Fitzgerald.
What a catch.
God Damn it.
That guy's good at marching down the field.
It looks,
doesn't look like we're in a prevent though,
so that's good.
You know what,
in the fuck I got,
here it comes,
they're going to be in two more catches.
They're going to be in fucking field goal position,
ripping out hard out there.
And,
um,
so anyways,
she ends up,
uh,
yeah,
just as a performer,
I respected it.
You know what I mean?
It's like if you're a comedian,
I'm doing my act and no one's listening.
No one's paying attention.
I'm just going to stop and I'm going to shit on the crop.
That's it.
Am I going to waste my time doing my material?
So why should she take her bottoms off?
It showed everybody the fucking world if they're not even gonna look at it.
Right.
So there you go.
There's my fucking stripper story.
But me and Nia never had a problem.
I think I want to see,
I've gone to a couple.
Okay.
Yeah.
My,
it will come.
Maybe one other with her.
MMM.
I gotta tell you it's not fun.
Okay.
It's not fun to go to a titty bar with your wife or even with other women.
It's just like everything.
I used to do a bit in my act about that.
Like when women started going to titty bars,
they would always go like,
you know,
at some point they always say,
this is,
this isn't as bad as I thought it was.
And it was,
isn't as bad as I thought it was going to be.
And the joke of my act was,
yeah,
cause you are here,
leave and it'll get evil again.
Um,
it's one of the worst things ever that happened that women started going to
titty bars.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
can't you just go to a fucking mail one?
Did you go to the fucking Dale one and have so fucking Goddamn Dick swinging in
your face?
If you're a lesbian then yeah,
come on in.
Have a good time.
Right.
It's just like they just constantly,
they just constantly have to be around us.
It's fucking unbelievable.
They think we're stupid.
They think we do dumb shit,
but they just can't get enough a doing every dumb fucking thing that we do that
down to the 28 fucking yard line.
Okay.
The Angel of the announcers are going to be in,
right?
No,
no.
The question is,
are they leaving too much until I'm on the clock or assuming that they hit this
field goal.
Okay.
I actually liked it.
This is going to happen cause if they kicked this field,
go right,
what are they going to be up by one or something?
Is that what it's going to be?
And then we get to watch Jimmy go down and do his thing.
He's going to get some experience.
I got to tell you,
I've been impressed with them.
He's playing all right.
You know that kid for fucking Dallas played all right.
And the dude,
they're on Tampa Bay.
I guess like Jason Law had said a long time ago.
He's like that guy,
even though we saw them get destroyed in the fucking Roseville,
he was still talking about him.
Jamieson,
right?
Don Jamison and Leslie,
it's the fucking comedian there from fucking a that,
that metal show.
Whatever he was saying that if,
um,
if a,
you know,
he had a couple of,
I feel like I had said,
so give me a couple of good white ops in that fucking quarterback and you could
do something in the NFL and it's looking like he's right.
He had four fucking touchdown passes today.
It's incredible.
Um,
of course.
Yet another thing that I missed here.
So anyways,
all right,
that's the podcast here.
I'm going to sweat this out or do you guys want me to hang in here?
I can't.
I can't cause it's almost 1130 and I have an early fucking flight.
I know you cardinal fans,
if you won,
you want to hear my fucking devastation.
But if we win,
you're not gonna hear me fucking Sharon.
All I know is that the colts lost.
And even if we lose,
I think that's fucking fair.
And if the colts actually had the same fucking record that we have at the end of
this fucking travesty of a Goddamn horseshit suspension,
um,
then I will say that God,
not only is God a fair God,
he's also a football fan and he is a man,
by the way.
All
he is a man.
So get that right out of your fucking head.
There's no way God's a woman.
Because if God was a woman,
he wouldn't create,
she wouldn't create,
you know,
a fucking animal like me.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in you on Thursday.
Promise.
I'll watch the fucking UFC event and a very excited about the first Ram's home
game.
I think it's so fucking cool that they're back in La and a,
it would be great if the the fucking cardinals would uh,
moved back to Saint Louis.
I wonder if saying love Saint Louis fans now that is going to be this weird
thing.
They don't have a team.
The older generation.
I bet it's still cardinal fans.
But then you won the younger ones that they still gonna follow the rams or do
they feel like they've been burned?
I have no fucking idea.
Go ahead and throw the ball again,
Carson.
Go ahead.
Fuck it.
Throw it again.
That now they'd not.
What are they doing here?
What is it there on the 33 yard line?
Am I what do you,
what do you add?
18 yards?
Is that what you had?
33.
It's like a 50,
51 yard at this point.
I'll tell you,
this is no poke poke.
All right.
I got to end this and sweat this fucking thing out.
We're up by to you mother fuckers.
All right.
Once again,
Bill Bellacheck showing why he's the greatest of all fucking time.
Look at this,
Huh?
It was a nine point spread.
Patriots are getting nine points at home.
Tremendous.
Fucking tremendous.
Were up by two with a minute.
55 left.
Um,
all right.
Dad said,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.